I went through my like cheating phase
and like I did I'm on the other side of
it so I can look at it very objectively
and go like you Faithful now yes fully
real like I don't even be looking at it
but do you ever look into DMs like I'll
go in the DM but the DM DMS on Instagram
this is what I will do like I'll go and
I'll like I'll bust the profile open
because I want to know what I'm
attracting you just went from I don't
look at women
I want to know who's who's why let them
get it you want to know how lucky your
girl is yeah yeah yeah
now would you share like if you got a
crazy DM would you be like babe look
look look where I'm at I tried and she
got mad I did try I think the girls
coming up in the world
high five like just be my homie right
now it didn't work out there what did
she say did she try DM she said I'll
beat them